secret santa 2020
christmas pudding please i gave this to
you like a year ago this is trash dude
hey everybody welcome to secret santa
2020. it's the time of the year we all
get together to celebrate having worked
hard made some cool videos watch some
cool stuff with you guys it was a great
time so how does secret santa work well
everybody here in the office was given a
recipient of a gift and it's secret to
everybody else so everybody has a gift
waiting for them on this table full of
delights then we come over here they get
their gift they sit down they open it
and then they have to guess who gave
them the present uh they get one guess
they get it right um they get a high
five and a round of applause they get
wrong they don't get any of that but
it's still a good time on top of that
we're going to be reflecting on the best
moments of 2020.
shall we begin
whoa there's tons of gifts on this table
people been putting them all week this
is like compared to like last year and
the year before that this is the most
extravagant secret santa table we have
ever had everyone has definitely gone
all out who's getting trash this year
for a gift
garbage i swear if you give me trash i'm
sorry carmichael but i'm not sorry
either take a seat on the couch gather
on the snack table me and jordan will
pick somebody we don't know who got you
the gift we're going to present them
while we're being live on corridor
digital.com
what do we got what do we got here man
who got me coupons
this is sick
oh my god
i love the office i take quizzes i have
coffee mugs i know everything if you
think you know it i already know it boy
griffin
[Applause]
hey jordan all i have to say is i'm
sorry about my michael scott
it was you
it doesn't look like michael scott i'm
sorry no thank you
no wait no
[Applause]
it's a master grade
nick it's not me
good friend of mine
yeah of course
of course i'll treasure this and build
it over the break and think of that
no way dude
i got tech decks dude
oh it's so sick have you guys seen
griffin do some of his slow-mo like
skateboard tricks like it's incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna go with daniel daniel
daniel
jake
oh
my god wow this is something i have
wanted to get into doing for a long time
and now i have the opportunity to do it
if anyone would have gotten it for me it
would have been sam was that am i right
or am i wrong you're wrong oh whoa
it's not sam who is it three texas trips
together oh it was your money you always
liked to get ipas around on texas so i
figured thank you
merry christmas appreciate you man a 25
gift card oh emailed to me once i guess
your name correctly if you guess oh and
i also
received
a guy
one
this is a traditional chinese cup to
prepare
loose leaf tea
[Music]
i thought it was definitely
[Applause]
thanks man i really appreciate that why
do i feel like this is from my
girlfriend
swedish fish there's literally flowers
in here
there's flowers in here somebody
obviously really cares about me who
would who would do this you know what
i'm just going to go with jake because
you know me the best i wish i would have
got you flowers buddy but i did not
well
i have something to admit i i'm in love
with you
i love it
i love you buddy
okay well that's a very revealing uh
return address on there oh dig it
i just want to say thank you to dean's
girlfriend
oh
man
i am now
[Applause]
am now
officially locked into being a css maine
aren't i thank you dean's girlfriend
[Applause]
oh my god yes
it is a nintendo pro controller for the
switch yeah hold on wait a second wait a
second didn't you already have one of
those i did and then it was in my
backpack when i tried to do something
stupid on a onewheel so i fell on my
back and smashed it oh
it's the perfect gift now you okay no it
wasn't nico
[Music]
sam
[Music]
welcome back welcome back
it's been too long it's been too long
there you go buddy dang what do you get
the man who already has everything
whoa whoa is this a flat top cooker
what the heck that is so crazy i've
always wanted one of these to do like my
own like hibachi and stuff nick
no
i thought that narrowed it down
wait who so who is it somebody yeah
you saw it on your uh on instagram
said that you like cooking and you like
camping so why not get the best of both
worlds dude that's what i'm saying to
you thank you hey man merry christmas
okay dude
some good gifts this year
i know who this is from
it's a lithophane of milo
oh and it's a family picture right here
oh wow
that's amazing that's such a good
picture of milo that you picked out
oh thank you so much i wanted to get you
more of these but this ended up being
way more challenging
than i expected so the idea is that you
put these on your window and that when
the sunlight is coming through your
windows they'll illuminate like a photo
oh this one's heavy
oh
i it's burning my fingers already
[Laughter]
there's only one person
who could
give me the sauce
that i
am owed
and now here it is in my hands matt
thank you thank you
this is awesome
these flavors will uh delight me for
many weeks to come
there's five gifts inside oh my goodness
open them in order obviously
[Music]
oh my god dude this is a pipe dream this
has been a pipe dream and now
it's finally possible hiking the pacific
crest trail which is like this crazy
long trail from california to washington
i think you will definitely need this
while doing what you want to do
oh oh my god
okay freaking airport security took my
water bottle so this is a really helpful
gift actually it was water it was water
i swear
yeah i see you wear these a lot you
could use it on your adventure and to
hide your receding hairline
wow okay
no it doesn't say that oh i love it look
at that shape wow this is amazing good
god
you're gonna need this for your next
gift
it's like a multi-stage gift
bleach
okay that's too far
bleach
you're the perfect pairing
see photo attached first not only does
it seem like you need these but these
will definitely be needed during your
adventure keep them clean and white
merry christmas peter
hey it sucks i'm kind of embarrassed
about my socks and so now i don't have
to be
jordan i knew it i knew it yeah
he had made eye contact with me early
and i was like no thank you so much
that's so sweet i tried i don't want him
to mess up opening them you did a great
job
doctor jake watson
all right i almost can guarantee you
this is whiskey
[Applause]
dewar's 12.
thank you i will happily accept this um
wait
nick
son of a [ __ ]
nick and i have been secretly giving
this to each other
since like 2016.
it started because we got it in the mail
and it was like in the it was in the
kitchen
and then we started like throwing it at
each other and then we started hiding it
like under each other's desks and like
in each other's desk drawers the last
time i put it in his like his suitcase
to go to mexico with his family i gave
this to you like a year ago
all right i'll be waiting
it's like a little two-parter
nick there could be a there's a lot of
shrimps potentially fitting inside this
box
[Applause]
keep
[Music]
i know who this is this is clinton dude
oh clint already oh [ __ ] wait a second
so someone
someone knows about my film scanning
need we need a film scanner can you send
us a film scanner
it was you
[Music]
thank you
i knew nick needed a film scanner
because he told me he needed a film
scanner
several times
this is like my new lullaby for when i
sleep funny little bag looks like it has
clint's name on it am i up
let's go
all right i'm just going in i'm just
going in
it's a freaking hot dog son
wait it's not even a hot dog
this is trash dude
what's in there
[Applause]
it's like someone someone planned this
this is clint's real gift we don't know
who gave it to him but
see mike wanted to fit in the inside
joke because he just happened to be here
today
he's a weird way of unwrapping first an
amazon box all right
oh my god it's a kombucha brewing kit
that's amazing i've been trying to make
some of this on my own for a long time
it was nico he's standing he's standing
here the whole time
thank you nico it was me
thank you nico thanks you bet awesome
yeah thank you
all right all right
before i open this i think whiskey's a
very appropriate moment for this um i
just want to say my favorite moment of
2020. my favorite moment of 2020. my
favorite moment of 2020 there's so many
great moments i have two favorite
moments of the year i got hired in 2020.
well i'm obviously going to jump on the
train with jordan and say my favorite
moment was obviously getting hired again
being hired full time finally for the
sake of originality my favorite moment
was also getting hired the website
launch that was really really big felt
really good it was like months of work
between me and jake and scott and a
bunch of people definitely watching
markiplier
train a pug how to sit and shake in less
than two hours
that was amazing and it's on note sorry
it's not a cord our crew go watch that
my favorite video is probably the who
broke the tv episode it was 2019 really
home alone rated r is like the funniest
thing
nah man it was just
what year is that my favorite video
moment was definitely boss town two like
the guys put what that was
20 20 moments come on and everyone lose
track of this year so much oh man all
right all right
oh my god well let's do a different one
then they let me create this south park
kind of animation which was so stupid
and also like absolutely crazy that i
was just like doing all of the voices of
all you people
in my room alone i'm not gonna be like
everybody else and pick a moment that
wasn't this year
the nerf drone video nerf drone nerf
drone is a masterpiece i think everybody
else was in texas griffin you were here
too yeah it was just like the three of
us in the studio and i i slept on that
very couch to get that video done my
favorite moment in that video was
actually the end when jan tells ren that
he's proud of him
favorite video um i'm gonna have to give
that to ren your 360 camera on a drone
video was incredible yes
um thank you i remember watching the the
outro sequence in that video and it just
blew my mind so
shout out to ren good job man the first
favorite moment of the year is when we
were filming the arnold schwarzenegger
competition this is your moment it's one
of two one two we were doing the bro
claps wren you were with jordan and we
were reviewing the tapes and i think
nico was the one who called ren and
jordan's clap measly measly 82.2 and
wren
wren he was he was not having it and he
said measly
measly
miss beasley
[Applause]
and it was the most measliest sounding
way you could say measly and it was like
we laughed for a lot it has to be
probably between finally getting ren's
drone out of that dang tree
how you feeling
untangled in the branches
or
the first time we watched through uh
willy wonka are rated
when clint burned his hand on the
incense
[Laughter]
my favorite moment of 2020 was the day
we sat down into visual effects arts
react for the very first time
god damn it
no okay so i want to say that my
favorite moment was when i defeated jan
with the nerf drone but honestly like
sitting on the couch with whoever i'm on
the couch with shooting visual effects
artists react is like some of the most
rewarding and fulfilling like
entertainment that i get and it the fact
that like so many people get to watch it
is just absolutely incredible to me so i
think a big
indicator for me when i realized wow
this is a really really cool opportunity
was when we got matt aitken in the
studio the visual the lead visual
effects supervisor from weta digital
who was like super cool with us and that
was like that was a really really cool
defining moment for me in my opinion my
second favorite moment was when we were
in texas it was like just a week of
spending time with everybody one of the
coolest moments on those tesco strips
was showing dean saving private ryan for
the first time when we did the the the
render challenge in the loading dock
when everyone was still super paranoid
about like kovid
and we were like how do we do this how
do we keep filming and like even i was
like kind of stressed out that day but
we'd spend so long like weeks at home
and finally coming back into film
together was pretty great so we just hit
the pandemic we were all working from
home you know we weren't really sure
what was going to happen how we're going
to make any of this work like what the
future held you know we all were like
hey um
we're going to make all this function
together
like we always have i realized that at
that point we were gonna be okay we were
gonna make it through it all just fine
that level of appreciation and trust and
respect for one another i think is
something that i see every day
with everyone here and so that means
more to me than
anything
honestly so
thanks jake
[Music]
also that minecraft video we shot was
really cool uh with the costumes i
thought that was pretty fun
was that last no that was that was last
year yeah yeah that was that was 2019.
so that was 2011.
yeah
oh wait wait yeah okay
sorry it's been a long year
before everyone leaves i brought bonus
gifts for everyone because i want to
spread some extra cheer here
12 month aged
decadent
christmas puddings
if you've never had an english dessert
christmas pudding these things are the
best here we go guys
everyone please thank you sam amazing
yes i have these shipped from england
christmas pudding please more pudding
12 months matured
[Music]
oh boy it's one
[Applause]
to all of you watching this video thank
you so much for joining us here at
corridor for watching our videos for
supporting us
even just just watching videos amazing
that you would take a few minutes of
your day to watch the stuff that we make
and enjoy it and connect with us on that
so thank you thank you for watching
everything
can't wait for 2021 we got some big
plans and big ideas it's gonna be a
really cool year some really cool
projects
can't wait to take all you with us on
that journey all right see you in the
new year